like so many people uh so many
well-meaning people
i was really upset by what i was reading
about climate change
um and now by the way with california
being on fire i'm even
more upset but uh all i was doing was
occasionally sending out an angry tweet
you know i was what i call uh and what i
call a slacktivist
um and i knew that that wasn't gonna cut
it so
i got involved with this non-profit
called
arctic base camp and dr gail whiteman
who actually lives and teaches in the uk
and their whole point is to study the
science of climate change from the point
of view of the arctic their
catch phrases what happens in the arctic
doesn't stay in the arctic
i decided to document it and i realized
that i needed to do
something more than just a couple of
angry tweets
you've obviously got a huge following
from the office you've obviously got
a lot of influence on twitter but
did people find that it was a bit of a
turn off because it was a serious
subject compared to comedy what sort of
response did you get
the response has been exactly what you'd
expect you know there's climate change
deniers who
have all of their usual kind of talking
points and
people that are very concerned but what
we were trying to do with this
particular show
was reach that that middle demographic
that might be confused that might be in
the middle it might be on the fence
maybe they live in mid-america and
they've got a conservative uncle
who doesn't buy the science and then
they've got friends at school that do
buy the science
and they don't know what to think so
this was really a show for them
what evidence is there that you
succeeded with that
i don't know about the evidence i mean
unfortunately you can't kind of
read the tea leaves of the comments on
the youtube page and to kind of
determine
the outcome but that's all we can try
and do
just try and nudge the needle a little
bit
here and there try and shift uh
consciousness
it's the same thing that's happening in
the united states right now with racial
justice you know
like there's a whole set of people that
they're never gonna change their minds
they're never going to believe that
there's
such a thing as white privilege or that
african americans
are suffering in systemic racism forget
them
they're never going to change but maybe
some people in the middle that we can
cajole and tweak and cokes and reason
with
that uh might come on board back in the
in the united states at the moment
you're experiencing wildfires you're
experiencing
really hot temperatures do you think
that those sorts of conditions
make people think twice data doesn't
work
but for some reason these extreme
cataclysmic weather events
that weren't happening with this kind of
intensity and regularity
20 or 30 years ago are starting to shift
the needle and starting to shift the
dial the rest of america just like the
uk europe and the rest of the world
has been severely affected by
coronavirus how much do you think that's
thrown people
off course in terms of really gathering
momentum to deal with climate change
obviously an international pandemic that
is
actively killing people uh is going to
take priority and it should take
priority
it's not an either or okay it's yes it's
a priority but there is
is not like let's forget climate change
let's forget racial justice and only
work on the pandemic right now no
we need to work on all of these things
and if anything
the pandemic can be this is a test run
for humanity
working together to overcome issues of
great odds
uh of great scope a great international
scope
we can do this as a human species
inhabiting this planet
not as the denizens of bolivia and the
netherlands and mongolia all just
working in their little
fiefdoms but working together
internationally after
this pandemic we can't go back to normal
we really we really cannot afford to go
back to normal
this affords us an opportunity for a
giant
reset you know a giant reboot uh
of our priorities uh moving forward in
the absence of
any kind of global leadership or
leadership from central governments
how important is it do you think for
individuals to take action
this is my favorite topic of all and
this is one of the most important topics
there is
this is the trouble with climate change
and it and it sucks
sorry there's no better word for it is
that i
as an individual can't do very much and
that is incredibly frustrating
so you have a lot of people thinking
well i'm just one person
i can eat beef you know i can have lots
of food waste i can drive a
you know an old truck that creates a lot
of diesel exhaust
what difference do i make i'm just this
is seven billion people on the planet
giant corporations and giant governments
what difference do i make
but you make a huge difference we make a
huge difference we all make a huge
difference because yes one person
doesn't
uh tip the scales but you know a
thousand
maybe ten thousand does then if a
hundred thousand people are all doing
the same thing
if a million people quit eating beef if
10 million people
start to reduce their their carbon
footprint if a hundred million people
start changing their ways
start commuting with bicycles instead of
with cars
all of a sudden we can see an impact so
we need to shift our behaviors we need
to take our friends and family
and co-workers and facebook friends and
everyone else along with us
and we are going to need to make
personal sacrifices
we love in the western world to have a
life of total convenience where we can
hit a button on amazon and anything we
want shows up at our doorstep a day or
two later
but we're going to have to shift things
to have a longer term
view we've got to plant trees support
environmental organizations
and most importantly we have to vote for
science
vote for people that are behind the
science do you feel optimistic
i feel optimistic that
big changes can be made and we can get
ourselves out of the worst
of this um it's very easy to get
pessimistic when you look at
the data and we look at some of the
things that happen
but there is a movement among young
people and that's where i feel my
greatest optimism
is what we just explored in the idiot's
guide to climate change
is that this leadership like greta
tonberg who i got to interview
and katie heider and so many other
people that
young women people in their teens in
their 20s are leading the charge
and helping make the change and we need
to get out of the way
allow them to lead and that's really
inspiring the amount of young people
that are behind the kind of drastic
change that humanity is going to need to
make
to fix this thing